I heard that in the first we infer
meatiest there was a lot of outtakes a
lot of David stuff that didn't get in
and no little I mean there's probably
lots of extra stuff that I wanted to
have David sort of dancing in sort of
the disco deck of the ship then you know
when when the credits rolling that sort
of might be quite a funny to do like a
Napoleon Dynamite for the character but
really didn't go first and I understand
why you've learnt the dance in you know
I thought you did learn today no I mean
I've done the robot probably back in
1987 you know when I was going through
the breakdown phase I love you went to a
breakdown oh yeah I love the fact that
breakdowns made it to fossa and there
was a break dance club you know Harry
Harry yeah
what is break dance break time yeah I
mean I you know what break-dances
all surprise right now Kevin we know I
know I did you want to teach it
[Applause]
great size is a law could you do some
road might rip something every time okay
using herbal afflicts swan dive like
okay do you want to know no Davis I
don't have a thousand years
the BBC great michael fassbender I could
I could try from here
I better take this off okay let me
forget mixed into microphones already in
the pocket I don't need to hear sound
effect honey because instance to finish
the peak that will take it our animals
shove it in tomorrow looks like
happening you're going to do it either
but amazing okay here's the music
[Music]
Gary okay okay without me you know I
think you're one Gary Numan an influence
for Walter the robot
[Applause]
that was beaten michael better
[Applause]
you